les corridors sont comme des labyrinthes
il y a du monde partout le va-et-vient
est constant chaque étage se ressemble
du linge des enfants qui courent ils
sont 1253
Ukrainiens à bord de ce village flottant
un immense bateau de croisière en créé
au port de talines pour héberger
temporairement les rescapés de la guerre
en Ukraine
Irina est arrivé à la mi-octobre tout
simplement soulagé d'être en vie elle
s'est habituée très rapidement à vivre
dans quelques mètres carrés avec ses
petits
[Musique]
de la qualité de l'air à la centrale
nucléaire de zapporisia sous occupation
russe constamment surveiller fouiller à
la vapeur d'être kidnappé comme l'ont
été nombreux de ses voisins comme tant
d'autres elle a différents choix
déchirant quitter l'Ukraine mais le
faire par la Russie
on a étudié toutes les options mais
c'était la seule possible dit-elle
rattrapé par le stress d'avoir eu un
parcourir plus de 2000 km en territoire
ennemi pour arriver ici en Estonie
of course
avoir été soumis à des fouilles
humiliantes dans ce qu'on appelle les
centres de filtration pour entrer en
Russie
séparés des femmes et interrogés par les
services de sécurité russe le FSB
US
raconte comment des agents du FSP l'ont
traité quand il est arrivé en Crimée un
passage obligé des heures d'humiliation
à faire des push-ups même et appeler des
biens malgré lui son allégeance à la
Russie
c'est la seule façon de s'en sortir
les autorités estiment qu'au moins 2
millions d'ukrainien ont été forcés
comme lui d'entrer en Russie pour sortir
de leur pays
un exode de masque le gouvernement de
l'Ukraine considère comme une
déportation masquée de ces citoyens qui
n'ont plus de toi ou plus rien à manger
limite trop dit que plusieurs de ses
amis Ukrainiens se sont en effet
résignés à s'installer à Moscou parce
qu'on leur offre de l'aide et de
l'argent mais ça lui donne mal au cœur
il lui reste des photos du squelette de
ce qui était leur appartement le salon
la cuisine la chambre de sa fille
il y a sur ce bateau autant d'histoires
de survie que d'histoire d'horreur des
gens qui refusent de les raconter à la
caméra de peur que leurs proches soient
puni car ils sont encore soit sous
occupations en Ukraine ou coincé ici à
la frontière russe en attendant de
traverser en Europe il n'y a pourtant
que 200 mètres qui séparent des
centaines de réfugiés de l'Estonie les
plusieurs ONG rapportent que les
douaniers russes les sortent des autobus
et les font attendre des jours dans le
froid ou sous la pluie avant de les
laisser partir c'est souvent ici que les
interrogatoires sont les plus corsés
derrière nous mais tout le monde nous
dit la même chose une fois qu'on
traverse ces gris blanches après des
mois d'occupation russe après des mois
de cavale on peut en faire respirer
comme il faut
c'était une délivrance pour Serge gay
qui a payé des passeurs 300 dollars pour
sortir de redston juste avant le
référendum au mois d'octobre le pire
pour moi c'était de traverser la Russie
et d'être interrogé dit-il
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour
m'assurer de m'en sortir un dette
arrêté par le FSB éliminer les
applications des nouvelles occidentales
de la BBC des nouvelles ukrainiennes en
fait de prétendre qu'il écoutait la
propagandeuse
parce que je sais dit-il ce qui arrive
aux hommes qui affiche leur soutien à
l'Ukraine dans les camps de filtration
russe
des hommes comigores dont le tatouage
aux couleurs de l'Ukraine qu'il portait
sous sa bague lui a value d'être arrêté
et transporter de force dans un camp de
détention
sur une planche de bois avec d'autres
compatriotes c'est là en cachette qu'il
a décidé de brûler son tatouage avec du
charbon pour s'en sortir vivant
retrouver ses proches et recommencer à
zéro en Europe
et pour chaque famille qui quitte le
bateau une autre doit arriver
cette autobus est arrivé à Tallinn ce
soir mais sans les réfugiés qui étaient
pourtant à bord quelques heures plus tôt
quand il a quitté Saint-Pétersbourg on
nous dit qu'ils ont été retenus à la
frontière russe on ne sait pas pour
combien de temps leur chambre les attend
mais leur sort reposent entre les mains
de la Russie